welcome back to dc thursday everyone
i'm pete soderling i'm the founder of
data council
and the data community fund and i am
excited to be your guide through
the crazy sprawling expanding modern
data ecosystem
as you know we have regular guests on
the show who are
typically open source data tools
contributors or authors or startup
founders
in in the data ecosystem and today i'm
very excited to
welcome ori raphael who is the
co-founder
and ceo of upsolver so
rory welcome to the show thanks pete
great to be here thank you for having me
so ori um i want to get started and talk
a little bit about about your background
which is something we typically do
on the show um talk to us a little bit
about
your early career and how you got into
data well
my early career my first job was in
israel i was
i went to the army for six years and i
spent
that time in the israeli intelligence
and my first job
was a database engineer so i started as
kind of
a person in this community i was given
the choice
between engineering and data and i chose
data and never
never looked back and we had thousands
of database instances so we had quite a
decent scale our dba team was very big
and we're basically the pivot point
around all data analysis so it was a
very
interesting first position for me at the
age of 21.
and this is probably um is this the days
of oracle when oracle was big or did you
use something else
oracle and sql server at the time
okay got it oracle was the biggest for
us and i started with oracle
got it um and did you start um to use
open source data tools um at some point
uh
following that yeah so we
we've evaluated hadoop in different ways
but it always was
i would say more on the marginal side
and
after that when the no no sql started so
we've used cassandra and we used elastic
and redis and like a whole bunch of open
sources
got it um and and what were some of the
key learnings from
the early part in your career how long
did you spend um at the
in israeli intelligence by the way i
spent
six years actually seven years
eventually and
i finished leading all of their data
integration so starting databases
eventually went back more to
esb or to etl depending on the
on the time and what are my some of my
key
takeaways key insights well
it's a very it's a very big question i i
think
uh i started my first days were oracle
days
so you know everything would be solved
with an oracle and i remember
learning by hand is that it's hard to be
locked to one vendor
like you have to use it even if it's not
the right tool you have to pay a lot
you're kind of dependent when there are
bugs
i think every person in my team had bugs
listed under their names in
in oracle we really took oracle to the
extreme because
it was still an rdbms a traditional
ldbms and we had
significant amount of of scale and also
and also use cases so i really remember
those early days in the dba
as a dba but also remember that so many
different users
in the intelligence used the databases
directly technical by the way
and very semi semi-tactical and hadoop
was always kind of on the side
something for some expert that some
remote
team would be uh would operate and i
remember
a lot how much databases allowed us to
iterate fast and every time that i come
to a problem
i usually first think about it in
database terms and not
in code terms so sql is very natural for
me
and it was natural for a huge amount of
users which is something that they took
away from
my experience there yeah got it that
makes sense
um and where did you go from the israeli
army
well i spent a few years i wanted to
really
create a have my own startup so uh
i i wanted i felt like coming out of the
army which is a non-profit organization
i needed to better understand what's
going on in the market and why companies
act as they act
so i did three years of b2b sales and
and then i found it up somewhere okay
got it awesome
well i'm excited to chat with you about
solver um
later in the show and want to understand
what you're building there and
and some cool things about the product
um but but before we do that
um i wanted to ask you about this open
lake house concept um i know it's
something that you've been
talking about and um you've been writing
about um you have a blog blog post on it
that um
that i was able to check out um sort of
what's the big deal
um first of all with the lake house lake
house sounds like we're
frankensteining a couple words together
a couple concepts together
um as sometimes we do in technology is
is this literally a combination
of a data lake and a in a cloud data
warehouse or
um how should we think about like what
what what does lake house mean
well some and i understand the confusion
completely i think that you can decide
that lake house is a database in that
case it will be closer to her house and
you can decide that it's an
architecture and in that sense it will
be closer to a data
lake and i think that companies like
snowflake
are interpreting lake house as a
database so basically a database built
on lake
foundation but it's a database just like
oracle like it's a
closed box internal storage and compute
uh
proprietary storage so everything is
very specific to snowflake but it's
built on lake
infrastructure would make it easier to
handle and more
more scalable on the other side there is
the
the data lake of the world and datadeck
is of course built on data like
infrastructure
but is it the house is it usable is it
easier requirable
all of that usability is has always been
a challenge for the data lakes of the
world so a person
thinking of about the lake house as a
data lake they want to make the
cost-effective lake usable a person from
the house
they want to make the easy to use house
scalable and more
cost effective and i think how different
companies are interpreting the term lake
house in a different way
and that's why i came i added the word
open i interpret it as a make
so i think storage is the most important
piece
in the database that's what's going to
dictate your performance and cost
and maintenance so giving that
i think that taking the data like that
didn't succeed in the past but gave all
of those benefits
and just make it usable is the right way
to go
gotta well um it's for sure there's a
lot of
um there's lack of efficiency and
there's challenges
around data lake architectures
historically
so um it seems like
you know maybe we have a sort of a
reference implementation
of a data warehouse a la snowflake or
redshift that seem and sort of feel to
be more battle tested
and and industry you know seeing
industry-wide adoption
um but maybe on the on the data lake
side um we're a little further
behind in actually understanding a
mature
implementation of a data lake um
so i don't know if you would if you
would say that the lake house is some
sort of advancement of um you know some
of the older
legacy concepts in a data lake sort of
brought into the modern era
if you would agree with that or not
i would agree with that i think that i
would i would definitely agree with that
i think that
[Music]
data lake is more it's harder to
implement
because it's an architecture and not a
single product so i'm not getting one
box
on the one side you have ingested on the
other side you have sql that's basically
a database
and it's easy to understand for the
organization
if you look at the architecture diagram
usually there is one thing
and if you look at the data lake you
need to stitch together the solution
from
multiple things multiple services that
of course adds
management complexity and is it a bad
thing
well if i would say it's a bad thing i
would also have to say that
microservices
is a bad thing because it's harder to
manage a bunch of microservices
comparing to managing one monolith
of course it's harder to do but what are
the benefits
i think that there is a lot of
similarity between the idea
the concept of an open lecos and the
concept of microservices that
if different smaller services let's not
be
tied to one vendor let's be able to
scale each server elastically and that's
not be locked
so locked as we are to database is
something that i've
felt in my uh in my early career so this
is the way i'm thinking about it
i see so so then to extend that i like
that analogy
um so essentially what you're saying
also conversely or as an extension of
that is that the
the data warehouse model is actually
more similar to the monolith
database model where you're sort of
talking to one vendor
for everything from you know query to
compute to storage
um so perhaps your argument then is that
um
the the the the data warehouse even of
today
um is very much a monolith whereas the
data lake is much more like a micro
services sort of decoupled
architecture completely and completely
stand behind
behind that and like look look even look
at the website for some of the big
companies so
uh look at databases for a long time it
was unified analytics platform unified
means that you use
data you use that tool and also for
snowflake
there they have you know you see
snowflake compute engine and a whole
bunch of use cases on top so you have
data lake data warehouse data
engineering so
all of them and it's great but
eventually why do you have to use no
free compute because you're using
snowflake storage
and what if when it says data lake on
top of snowflake there
maybe that's not the tool that you want
not saying that they're not
doing a good job maybe that's not the
best tool for you for your preference
for your users
what are you doing you're kind of you're
kind of stuck like you know you don't
have another option so
snowflake is a great tool but eventually
it's the same circle
same dynamics i had with oracle
15 years ago it's the same dynamic two
users have with it and i loved oracle
i enjoyed working with it but there was
some
some limitations got it well let let's
talk about uh on the on the data lake
side
um or the lake house side um what are
what are some of the challenges that
um you see that folks typically have in
sort of getting efficiency out of their
data lake
architectures before we talk about the
open
standard that you're proposing let's
talk a little bit about some of the the
real world challenges
um on the lake side of the house so to
speak
yeah so the pro the problem the problems
on the lake side can be
from data correctness to
to performance and the reason is that a
database really kept you safe
so i did insult update delete and then i
communicated with the table and
underneath that table there was
some kind of file system that i wasn't
aware of i didn't tried it
i didn't need to manage it i didn't need
to make sure it's correct like
everything i trusted oracle to give me
that
now i'm working with a data lake and
basically i'm writing code on top of a
raw file system
so this is why database were invented so
people wouldn't screw up
all their their entire file system so
that's why
the engineering on the data lake side is
one
more complex and second riskier like you
have to do what you're doing because
you're basically
putting on your shoulders the same
responsibility you once gave to oracle
which is
they're pretty good at doing this this
this kind of work
so i feel like that understanding how to
build a proper file system how to
partition it what file formats to use
what compression
file sizes all of that is on the company
implementing
the data deck and they need to know how
to do that and the second thing is
how to manage the human process and what
i've seen at least before observer
is that you have a data analyst team you
have a data science team and you have a
core data engineering team
and you trust your core data engineering
team to
with the risky and complex operation
which was kind of a problem to then get
that work into the heads of the analysts
and the scientists
you're kind of stuck only at coded
engineers and like my experience
with coded engineers they're super hard
to get
and their time is super valuable so
definitely this is not the thing that i
want to spend their time on
so i think giving access to the data to
all those data-based users
is something very very important to do
and a little missing
with data lake today that's data lake
3.0 let's give it
the same access we gave to the
the same developer access we had in
database
got it so um so
so what what about the so-called um
open or open source data lake formats
right there
there's um delta lake there's iceberg
there's hoodie there's um there's a
bunch of
formats that are in the open source um
on the data lake side i think you don't
necessarily see those all those formats
as necessarily
as open um perhaps as as their name
belies
talk to us a little bit about that
yeah so first of all if you look at
there there is a difference between
a hoodie and a party hoodie coming from
uber and an iceberg coming from netflix
and
delta they coming from databricks okay
netflix and uber have
different incentives so basically
they've built a metadata store
that gives more capabilities comparing
to the traditional hive metadata store
and they wanted to do it in order to add
asset compliance insert update deletes
and those kind of things into
into a data they can they open source it
so every person that's
going to use that metadata so we'll have
those capabilities
and the only problem i can see i can i
can see
that it's not as well adapted or
strongly adapted
as a hive metastar so usually there is a
compatibility
issue with using one of those tools
daltonic is
a different story and data lake is
basically databricks
uh format for uh for a data lake
that also solves the same types of
problems but delta x is
partially open source not fully open
source like
and uh it still has the same
compatibility issues so if it can and a
query engine didn't find the right way
to integrate with delta lake then you
can't really use
delta lake for example latina delta lake
connectivity is something that's been
talked about in a lot of uh in a lot of
blogs
and usually what you need to do is to
spin up an additional integration
between your data lake and the glue
catalog
so an athena will be able to read it and
that's kind of
doing uh going uh
in a kind of convoluted way so i feel
the need is there people need more
capabilities out of their hive
metastores
the update the lead the asset there is a
big need around it and i feel like this
is maybe the area where the data lake
market
needs to mature the most do i think
there is a solution in the market today
not yet still a little early and like i
would
put delta lake by the way uh i would put
them in the same bucket as snowflake
they are creating a file system that's
very specific to databricks
and most of the users like i can't i
can't of course say the statistics as
database but
i've heard over 80 percent and again not
saying that this is
well back this is a word of mouth so i
heard more than 80 percent of the people
using delta electric versus using data
breaks
so it's a very similar play to what
snowflake is doing and i'm sure you've
seen all the news around snowflake and
data breaks competition
so they're competing because delta x is
a competitive move
versus snowflake and it's small and kind
of the traditional data warehouse
then it is an open data lake in my
humble opinion
so so you're arguing that we need this
notion of an open cloud
data lake or open cloud lake house based
on
these types of sort of tightly coupled
interactions even
in certain kinds of data lake
architectures
um so so talk to us about the principles
of this open lake house that you're
proposing because i think this is really
interesting
so an open lake house has three three
layers
it has the the engines that are building
into the that sorry that are writing
into the layouts there are the engines
that are querying
and in the middle you have your data
store and i think
if i would need to define what's an open
lake house if you're using
open source storage format like apache
parquet or
c and you're using a an open source
metadata store like the aws catalog
or the apache hive metastore
then you're good like all query engines
are able to query that
data so uh of course on object storage i
didn't mention that so
on s3 with a table mapped to it from the
glue catalog
that would be an open like us there is
no engine in there with no query engine
in the world that would not be able to
consume
that uh that data that's the most so it
doesn't matter if you're athena
or presto or even snowflake um you you
can query
that file format that on on the object
storage
um directly from any compatible query
engine because the the file storage
itself is based on
uh it's it's based on open formats yeah
yeah and uh think about the the
the potential of data sharing between
engine like one of our public case
studies on aws one of app servers the
public case studies is a company name
iron source
they have they have a velocity of 3
million events per second which is
a lot of a lot of data and then they are
using
three different query engines at the
same time on the same copy of data
so bi liked one thing and the analytics
team like one thing and the data science
team like one thing and maybe the cost
would make
made sense with one tool in the
beginning of the of their journey
but then they decided to move to another
tool because they wanted to have their
own cluster
so things evolve and if the all the
query engines can share the same
copy of the data you get a lot more
agility and you don't have the same
overkill locking that we had 15 years
ago
and and what are your opinions on the
storage layer options
how do you compare formats and sort of
any insights on on how a team might pick
the correct
open format for their storage so
it's usually a discussion between apache
parque and apache aussie so there isn't
a lot of depth to it every time we've
tried to check
whether one is better than the other
we'll find marginal
improv marginal differences and
use case dependent and we decided to
standardize on apache parque
because it is more common and because we
haven't seen
big big differences when you're using
orc
so we prefer pancake but it's not based
on
that the technology is not good it was
just more popular
got it um and and how popular do you
think this
this open cloud like house format is
becoming um
you obviously feel like the world is is
ready for it you're out talking about it
and evangelizing it
um are you seeing the adoption sort of
tick up and in the way that you would
hope
yeah for for sure this is the golden age
of query engines so in the past that you
needed to
spin your own presto on uh
you know on something like an emr like
you needed to a cluster to manage
every time and now you have athena and
athena is a very
um well adapted
service for aws so the number of latina
users a number of
like companies using that service i
think it's one of the aws
most fast growing services and that's a
good sign
you can see starbursts and their success
and their and their uh this entire
recent fundraising you can see dremeo
you can see snowflake
bigquery redshift and azure synapse
all having their independent query
engines that
query open source data so like if i
needed to make the list of
options for query engines three years
ago i would have
one two and they're they weren't very
easy and
now i have like ten so uh i think we're
going to see more and more
query engines and we're also going to
see query engines that are more
use case specific like for example if i
could query the data from s3
and get apache droid-like performance
that's a very nice service
i don't need to get all my data into
droid which is the hard part and i still
get a very low latency on top of s3 so
that could be a query engine that adds
indexing
into it that's an example of a startup
you can have a query engine that
reads the data and follows the elastic
search pattern or the cassandra pattern
so i kind of see this open layouts
concept as you have your store on s3
you own it you as the as the customer
you own that store
and on top of that store you have a
whole bunch of apis
you have an sql api you have a low
latency sql api you have an elastic api
and nosql so all the databases that we
know i think that eventually there are
apis to data
and the data should be decoupled away
from them that's gonna
five ten years from now yeah i like that
vision i think you're right it is a
golden era for
uh for query engines and um this format
could potentially make a lot of sense
um i want to go to a question because um
daniel
has jumped in with a question
how do you handle in scala terms
covariant needs
all engines can read it and contra
variant needs
meaning das needs metadata not in other
formats to get good performance on the
system
do you have any thoughts on that can you
repeat that covariance you said
maybe a misunderstood i think he's using
scala terms
how do you handle covariant needs and
contravariant needs
i guess i'm not as familiar with the
term um yeah same here
but um maybe maybe daniel can jump in
and clarify
his example is regarding um where
a contravariant system is like to ask
that needs
metadata not in other formants not not
in other formats to get good performance
on the system
yeah i think i understand what i i hope
that i understand what he's saying
and he is right that one of the big
caveats of
getting data directly from an object
store like s3
is the low latency performance so you
need to go to the metadata store the
highmaster which is basically my sequel
and then i need to query it get the data
back go to the files
look in the parquet files understand
which one i need to open so there's a
lot of metadata
round trips that like there is a
every time you go to a presto there is a
fine uh that you need to pay
in the beginning before you can that's
that's kind of
uh there's a disconnect from real-time
dashboarding
and daniel is right and i think one of
the i said that metadata stores i see
them as a little uh
still a little early we need to push the
same level of statistics we add in
databases
into metadata stores and that's why we
wouldn't need to go
to every single uh
[Music]
there's a lot of room for optimization
there's and i also think that dremeo and
starburst are already doing some of that
uh
some of that work i completely
acknowledge what daniel said this is a
challenge
and i think that once all query engine
will be able to do sub second queries
from s3
and that's going to close a big gap
comparing to
traditional databases
very interesting um so
i want to i kind of want to touch on the
the third part of the architecture that
you mentioned
because um we talked about the storage
and we talked about the the query engine
layer um but this sort of is a bridge
into talking a little bit more about
what up solver does because
obviously um the data has to get into
the
the lake or the warehouse in some way in
the first place
um and i know you have some thoughts on
that um
uh but but tell us a little bit first of
all about what upsolver
does and and why you decided to start
the company and how that might fit in
so but i met my partner uh for
absolvering the israeli intelligence i
think he was the cto of the largest data
science group in the entire army at
the time we both knew databases very
well and we decided to work on a problem
in the advertising space
and by the way the advertising space and
the intelligence space are pretty
similar you're trying to understand what
people are doing so we started there but
there was big amounts of data we needed
to do
a lot of machine learning so two things
pushed us to choose a data lake
the first was cost because the volume
the second
is machine learning which is not a
well-suited use case for it for
uh for a database so
we looked at the the tasks that we
needed to to do and i i
remember looking at something some kind
of analytics breakthrough we needed to
do a traffic and i said
this would take me three hours to do an
sql as a dba myself
and then we needed to go find the data
engineer which was hard because it
wasn't such
interesting work to do and when we
brought that person it took them about
30 days to do that with spark
so what brought me into this business
is that i think that i want to turn data
decks to be more like databases with
their time to value and that's a pain i
i had experience personally and we
actually built
internal tools for ourselves so we would
be able to iterate faster
on top of s3 and eventually decided to
turn those tools into
into absorber yeah so we see ourselves
as
i hope at least we see ourselves as our
own
as their own users and we can relate to
any person coming from the database
world into the data lake
world and that's why we started the
company
so it's very much a a contrasting
approach from using the old hadoop
and spark tools so that that's based on
your
familiarity and love and appreciation
for sql and belief that
um data engineers could benefit from
um tools um to to move the data through
their systems
for sure so yeah so i think that
back in the back in the dup days uh some
would call
data like a science experience or
something you do for your
use case with too much data when you're
only thinking about cost and you don't
care about
the about usability and in the next
in the last few years we have been
proven that the future of databases is
data lake infrastructure
this is not a science experiment like we
need to store data
on object storage so now it's not that
people that are
early adopting like doing a sound
experience with hadoop that are moving
now into spark
those are all the database people that
are also moving to a data lake
they don't know a doof they don't know
spark they come from databases but they
have the same needs we need to build a
data store
on top of data lake infrastructure on
top of object storage
uh preferably in the cloud how are we
going to do that we are not speaking the
language
of hadoop and we are not really
interested in doing that this is not
this is the not uh promoting the value
of the business the value of the
business is to get insights out of data
that's our crowds well that's that's a
fascinating vision
um so so you see um
all the dbas in the world essentially
moving to
object storage on the cloud and and yes
they're going to need to learn
some new tools and um and understand the
difference between the
query engines and as you mentioned
before there needs to be some
advancements there
um but but your argument is that the
data lake is essentially
poised to become um the new the new
database of the cloud
yeah i'm
not say things that i'm not qualified to
say like data lake is definitely going
to be the data store for all databases
there's no doubt about it and but but
yeah data lakes will continue to live
in parallel with data warehouses or how
do you see
sort of that that emerging over time
so when i say data lake let's let's try
to
not confuse the audience in that sense
so when i say data like
infrastructure i mean let's call it
object storage from now on so i see all
warehouses
running on object storage and i see all
lakes coming working on object storage
so
once you're moving to object storage
that's basically changing the way a
database work with
local storage and you know replication
copies and all of that so that's the
change what i
that i mean that's going to happen will
data lakes and data warehouse coexist
i feel like there is no other option
like if i'm gonna use only a warehouse
that i'm stuck in
my i'm stuck with the other key locking
and it's the same problem
so i don't want to do that i want to use
the data lake but maybe the data lake
doesn't
work with my use case end-to-end because
it's not usable enough
but then i'm putting a data deck before
my warehouse
as a staging area and i'm putting only
the relevant data in the warehouse and
then i'm also not locked in the
warehouse all my data is
in the lake and obvious question is well
if all my data is in the lake can't i
query it there
well you can there are some limitations
over time those limitations are going to
be
less going to be less and less uh
limitation so i think the warehouse and
lake are already
already coexist today as the lake is
staging or before the warehouse
and i believe that we are going to see
more and more analytics use cases
opened uh happening directly in the lake
because
why send the data somewhere else and
like the warehouses of the world are
already giving an answer for it in this
form of
of a query engine that can work on
external stores in the form of external
tables in a sense
yeah especially if as you're saying um
some of the optimizations can be handled
at the query layer um for for different
kinds of
um analytical use cases i mean there
might be some limitations there because
um you know typically an integrated sort
of special purpose
database for analytics will sort of
control the format of the the data on
the disk
and do query optimization so perhaps
there may be some limitations in the
decoupling
um of the the query in the storage and
what can what can actually only be
affected on the query layer but um i
guess we'll see over time
you know how that model shakes out yeah
probably the query
what the the piece that the query engine
can add is indexing
they're not changing the data because
the data is shared by others they're
not allowed to do that but they're
adding their index and then when they
query
sometimes they query their index
sometimes they query the raw data that's
available for everyone and that's
actually
something i've seen for example with
several companies
yep for sure um well going back to this
this sql
etl use case um talk to us about
um common use cases that sort of you see
emerge surrounding this
this sql etl pattern i'm curious to to
hear more about how companies use that
yeah so let me start with the why so i
have the adobe
person going to the data the cloud data
lake they're moving from hadoop to spark
so
java chain to java and scala python
there is a change there but it's
basically the same interaction
but for the dba person or the database
of the
pers database practitioner or the
application that can be an engineer
an analyst they're not they're not going
to write that code
and they don't know all the best
practices they do understand sql
that's something very familiar for them
so what absolver
did is basically created the sql
language for etl
and so every every um
um phrase that you're gonna see there
is probably gonna be i have this source
column and i have this target column
and probably i'm gonna apply more
transformation on the source to get it
into the target
uh the reason we chose sql is
first people already have uh
you know like experience with sql so if
they want to do the transformation
they're going to go to absorb and say
should i learn this company's new user
experience
regardless of how good it is or can i
use the knowledge i already have
to write transformation that was the
first reason to have sql and once we did
that we
we saw a flow of data analyst users for
example
working with app solvers so people that
wouldn't do it before because sql is
really their
their language the second reason is to
show that the system is powerful enough
so you're looking at this
tool from a company called absorber and
well can this really do my use case
or is it this is a nice visual ui and
eventually it's gonna i'm gonna get
uh i'm gonna get to a glassing and what
uh
what we did is that we gave the full
power of sql so you can do etl joins and
etl aggregations and time windows so
kind of every possible operation you can
do in a database
you can do it the etl layer with app
solver it spoke for expressiveness and
it made us
i think it was adding sql to our
platform was maybe the
one of the biggest releases we've ever
done and it impacted go to market almost
immediately
because of those reasons because it
became easier and it was
clear to explain why is it powerful
that's really neat um so you use the sql
for
for the transformation of the data as
well um is is this sort of
competitive to dbt in that in that sense
well um just hang on let me let me
reconnect the stream
peter i'm not sure that i can hear you
right now i
i the last thing i heard is you asked me
about dbt and absorber
because we're both sql based and did you
get my answer or you want me to read it
to italy
yeah um could you reiterate that because
i i missed that we had some technical
difficulties here
um sorry about that no no problem
so uh i think the dbt and absorber are
solving a problem
in in a similar way but on different
parts of the the ecosystem
so dbt plugs on top of your warehouse
you're getting
a very powerful compute engine form your
cloud warehouse and dbt
helps you orchestrate work on top of
that
engine you're writing sql and you
orchestrate jobs and you're using the
sql you already know same concept as app
software
app solver works on top of on top of
objects
on top of s3 we don't have a compute
engine to push down the sql to
so we need to pulse and execute that sql
ourselves so absolver
i think built at least a half of the
logic that you have to have in the
database
just to compute the sql and if you want
to
do transformations on top of s3 in the
lake you're going to use a software if
you're going to do
transformation within the warehouse
you're going to use dbt similar
similar thing but the question whether
you want to round out
your transformation and of course there
are inventions and advantages and these
dungeons on both sides
and and what are the advantages to doing
the transformations over the object
storage itself
cost would be much much lower compared
to
like order of magnitude level
of lower cost etls are are not
very cost effective when they run on
warehouses the second is latency
so the way you you process data
in warehouses is that you're basically
running sqls and
chunks of data and what we're absorber
does is processing each event separately
so we can deliver the final data within
a
third third time is the charm for sure
so
just to answer what you said so i told
you that cost
is one thing latency is uh is
a second thing uh i think some people
would like to
do the i think that the more traditional
analysts might like to do the
transformation within their
warehouse so there that's how we used to
work in oracle
that's also what creates the lock-in
because the final data the refined data
that you're creating in the end
it's only available within the databases
you're not creating
that refined level in the beginning so
you're not you're not able to send it to
other databases it's only
within your cloud warehouse advantages
on this side costs
lock-in latency adventures on the other
side this is kind of
how people were used to do stuff in
oracle which is
good and familiar yep got it
well um i want to switch gears a little
bit because
i know that just from a sort of engineer
founder perspective
there's always challenges especially in
going to market
you know upsolver is a really
interesting tool it's
it's almost something that's so unique
that that
maybe people have never seen it before
or they know they've never thought it
was possible because it sort of carves
out
a new space in the data workflow um with
sort of an old
standby standard tool sql but it's
basically creating
new space i'm just wondering like from a
you know from a founder ceo perspective
what were some of the biggest lessons
you learned from bringing up solver to
market
i think the biggest lesson by far
is that uh you need to measure and and
attack
friction at every lit uh every point
every
level possible and i'll make it more
concrete
i remember getting started how do you
deploy absorber are you using it as a
cloud service or are you using it
as a private vpc buying your own private
gpc
that was the ques in 2017 this was a
legitimate question so
no one was ravishing was not not that
well uh
it was not that popular back at the time
and we
like the team said well you can go to
the security team and explain and do
everything
but explaining takes a lot of time we
don't have
time and effort and money to actually go
ahead and explain
so i think that the from a product
perspective we've been looking at
product to sell
from day one and seeing how can people
start using it
with asking as few questions as possible
and also avoiding those friction points
and i think sql was another one okay
i've heard analysts say after pocs
well it's very nice what you've built
here but i know sql this is the language
of databases why are you serving me with
something new
and uh and i i heard that feedback a
couple of times before we decided to
work on sql
and i have at least of about 10 things
in absorber that i feel we have built
just to eliminate friction even though
we could be considered
right but right isn't winning and that's
kind of the
biggest lesson yeah got it yeah well
fascinating lessons um with with these
innovative products
but um yeah it's it's uh really
interesting to hear your story ori i'm
curious like what's your vision for this
open lake house concept um
what sorts of feedback and involvement
are you looking for
from the community um on this
well i i hope that people will get
educated on what's an open lake house
they're going to look in their
architecture well this is
following a good design pattern this is
i want to get an open lake house because
that's what i believe in i think that i
want a future pools i want to be able to
work with multiple engine
i want to reduce costs and i understand
what it's it's costing me
and i hope that the people on the other
side taking a data warehouse so that
all the way will also understand the the
other options so i hope that
what people are going to get just from
that open lake house content that we are
creating
is that they get educated and i think
people are very thirsty
to get to to know that information so
how do i architect for the cloud
how is analytics different in the cloud
what abstractions that i have that i
didn't have in the on-premise day
what's a good reference architecture
what's the bad one how did other
companies do that
i think all of that information is very
is very important and in demands i hope
we'll be able to address
yeah well it's very important as you say
for
engineers and implementers to understand
sort of the differences in the tools
they're using and how they fundamentally
work and so
um you know it's very hard to to make
these decisions without
a clear understanding and education um
understanding sort of some of the design
patterns and architectural differences
and
and how these tools work so um yeah it's
been really fascinating to
to have this conversation with you and
to kind of deconstruct
um some of the aspects of what an open
lake house means
um yeah i really really appreciate you
taking the time and
chatting with us and i'm curious um if
folks want to try up solver
as well um where can they do that
well they have several options the first
one is go to the website
click on start free and just work with
the platform there is a community
edition which is free forever with all
features except scale because
we need to pay for that but other than
that you can use everything
and we have a few quick starts and we
are there you can start to
experiment the platform on their own
that's option one option two is that we
have dev days on a monthly basis
and on dev days we are giving guided
hands-on labs
on how to take a use case and implement
it in the software and
today in the aws style in the future
also in the azure cloud
and then google cloud as well and
basically you're building something
that's end-to-end not just enough solver
you're taking
data that's just dumped on object
storage and eventually making it
queryable in sql
and you do everything in 90 minutes on
your own
so that's very cool thank you yeah that
day has been popular so
that's option number two option number
three talk to us
yeah awesome um well we have another
question actually um from the audience
that i want to take before we sign off
or if you have the time
sure um so manu is asking what's the
minimal poc footprint for upsolver if i
want to try on my own super private data
what's the simplest and fastest way to
try upsolver
well he said simple and super private
data super private
yeah yes so for the super private
data i would do a private vpc
you see so when you go into the platform
after you sign up there is a cloud
formation script
that we launch and you can i'm assuming
that it's aws it's there is the same on
azure
so once you do that uh you can choose
private vpc
and then would be deployed into your
account the way
it works is that we are able to manage
the cluster
in manu's account so basically spin up
and spin on ec2 instances
but our employees don't get access to
the s3
bucket so we can never access the stl we
cannot even access the instances
so mano is is guaranteed on the aws
level
that we will not touch their data but he
will be able to play with absolver
that's the card right
awesome um well that sounds great and
ori if
folks have other questions for you um
what's the best way that they can reach
out to you
i don't think you're on twitter are you
i think that i am on twitter
are you okay but
yeah uh ori ori absolver.com
correct i always answer my email and
linkedin
twitter all of them works okay awesome
that's the best one
awesome well we're happy to help you um
advertise this open cloud lake house
format i think it's super interesting
and um and a thoughtful architecture
that more folks need to consider
so um yeah i was really grateful that
you took the time to come in
and share with us today um and we'll you
know continue to send feedback from our
community and send folks directly to you
um in case they're interested in in
being helpful um or joining any sort of
consortium that i think
um you might be interested sort of
secretly in in starting
sounds good yeah well well thanks for
joining us ori we'll talk to you soon
bye and to everyone else out there
thanks for your patience with our minor
technical difficulties today
i'm glad you stayed tuned in to the end
of the show
next week we'll have another awesome
guest on dc thursday and we'll talk be
talking to
tom banz from soda data he's the
co-founder and cto
about data monitoring um so don't miss
that episode
don't forget to subscribe to the youtube
channel hit the bell icon to get
notifications about our next episodes
and we'll look forward to seeing you
soon next week
here on dc thursday thanks everyone